they can walk like humans or four-legged
animals they can slither like snakes and
yes even crawl like insects like hexa
here over just the past couple years
robots have exploded sometimes literally
but they're showing up all over the
place and taking an astounding range of
forms which roboticist have largely
borrowed from nature we're talking
salamanders and even octopuses because
it turns out nature kinda knows what
it's doing when it comes to locomotion
so come with us on a journey through a
fascinating world of biomimicry a
cornerstone of modern robotics nothing
will bite you I promise
evolution is the greatest creative force
the world has ever known it's helped
animals conquer land see and pair with a
galaxy of body forms so it's here where
a roboticist often look for inspiration
first up snake bob these robots are
basically composed of about 16
individual motors or actuators some
servo motors and how they're actually
arranged allows us to take on these
these three-dimensional shapes with
amongst other things allows me to do
things like sidewind so you can actually
see the robot here is moving a lot like
desert cooling sidewinding snakes while
snake bot is decidedly serpentine these
researchers never set out to copy a
snake muscle for muscle and bone for
bone they wanted its mobility stakes can
climb and squeeze through tight spaces
and so can snake bot copying a snake's
physiology exactly it would be both
impossible and unnecessary but what's
special about snake bot is it can
actually pull off maneuvers like this
that a real snake never could it won't
be jumping any time soon but salto
certainly is this one-legged robot was
inspired by a critter called the bush
baby which has a vertical leap of six
feet the bush baby uses something called
super crouched posture where it stores a
bunch of energy and suddenly releases it
same with salto but that's just the
start of the challenge of not only
jumping but bounding off things salto is
controlled by setting its orientation in
the air
based on where it is how fast it's going
where we want it to be and how fast we
want it to be going so in the air it
simply picks an orientation to land with
once it lands we detect contact apply a
little burst of energy to get it back
off the ground and then repeat moving
rather more methodically is micro tug
from Stanford inspired by the stickiness
of gecko feet this tiny wonder can pull
2,000 times its own weight that's like
you dragging 300,000 pounds the secret
is a whole bunch of tiny rubber hairs
that stick the robots in the ground as a
winch pulls the object a group of them
tethered together can even pull a car
but why crawl when you can fly at
Caltech researchers have built a robot
bat which again will not bite it's got a
skeleton of carbon fiber and wings made
of silicon the robot bat is another case
where researchers didn't bother strictly
copying an animal these wings have nine
joints instead of 40 you'd find in a bat
natural selection crafted the bat over
millennia but roboticist took that
design and simplified it so taking
inspiration from the physiology of
animals is one thing but what about
replicating evolution itself this is
direct it's actually teaching itself to
walk by falling down it tries new gates
and selects the ones that work best in a
certain environment out here in the snow
it automatically adjusts to lower its
center of gravity for more stability
thus it adapts to an environment like a
species might in nature so robots can
mimic animals and even evolution but
they can also mimic collective behavior
ants are great at two things ruining
picnics and working together to build
their homes
microbots collaborate like ants to build
impressive structures like this lattice
some robots deposit glue and others add
rods we can have robots that specialized
in handling active components you know
like resistors LEDs that means Mike
robots could work together to build
complex structures that are sturdier
than what you'd get with 3d printing and
biomimicry can also help scientists
better study and protect animals take
this robotic fish from MIT it swims by
pumping water into two opposing chambers
in the tail researchers remote-control
it
with radio waves which don't work
underwater but with acoustic signals one
day the robot could go fully autonomous
to blend into a coral reef that could
give scientists unprecedented insight
into these ecosystems and then there's
fembot yes that's its actual name take
taxidermy bird stuck on some wheels it's
both hilarious and useful biologists
Gail Petrocelli uses it to spy on save
grass species under stress over the last
decade or so they've been the focus of
one of the biggest conservation efforts
in US history this is what the robot
looks like without its bird show the
shape is a fiberglass mold of a body
from an online taxidermy store it's kind
of got a crazy escaped rotisserie
chicken with some sort of something s
and am going on in there look what it's
halfway built but but this is all
elastic this is nylons I actually used a
pair of Spanx so it ripped apart fembot
is helping Patras le better understand
the sage-grouse so she can better
protect it so from a robot bird to a
robot snake to a robot whatever this is
machines inspired by nature are making
big strikes
[Music]